are you ready for more uncharted  goodness with the Lost Legacy then I've  got news for you I'm Tony this is a game  spot news update and for everything  Naughty Dog be sure to subscribe it  turns out the new chapter will contain a  level set in the Western God's mountain  range in India and it's gonna be a big  one designer James Cooper discussed this  in an interview with Game Informer he  said this is the single largest level  we've ever done in uncharted  geographically it's much bigger than  Madagascar which was previously our  largest level The Lost Legacy is headed  to ps4 sometime in 2017 and unless  Naughty Dog hands the reins over to  another studio that'll be the end of the  Uncharted saga for another epic  adventure you can check out 15 minutes  of gameplay for middle earth shadow of  war and for all the biggest game news  you're already in the right place  [Music]  you  [Music]